I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her
I did not oh hi mark I love my eyes I
didn't miss anything
that's what what time
jaws 3 this movie is shit it was
originally in 3d released in 1983 during
a very weird period where Hollywood
decided to make a lot of horror films in
3d like Friday 13th part 3 in a medieval
part 3 and jaws 3d but for the very
first time we are actually able to see
this movie in 3 din shirts that looks
good I know gonna cool that actually
looks really good but it looks so cheesy
and tuning it does it looks normal right
there I know it's like oh that's where
it's supposed to be
now starting on your face yeah
for years I watched this as a kid and
wondered like what is with all these
weird shots of like the shark coming at
the screen and all these elongated takes
of things like pointing at you now that
we have the blu-ray we were actually
able to watch it in 3d for the first
time today this is my friend Matthew
Brando you may remember him from the
review the other side of the door how
are you today sir was a pleasure meeting
Jedi so Matt do you have any memories
with jaws 3 because for me it's kind of
a guilty pleasure
it's shit the movies bad but it's not
jaws of Revenge bad right I remember
growing up as a kid and I actually liked
the concept and I thought it was a
decent film like 6 out of 10 ish maybe
you always watched it because as a kid
you loved jaws as you did as an adult it
kind of gets worse and worse every time
you watch it it's really sad though
because jaws is like an Indiana Jones
it's a Jurassic Park it's a Star Wars
thing you grew up with it it was so good
and it really stinks that the sequels
they just kind of fall off every time
you watch them yeah each sequel got
consecutively worse three was always
kind of like for me like you said it was
a good concept you had an idea a shark
loose and SeaWorld there there could be
so many things that could come about I
think we were watching it we were
drawing comparisons to Jurassic Park
there's a similar feeling with Louis
Gossett jr. running around trying to be
called him the Hammond of the movie I
think it got lost in the whole gimmick
of trying to create this 3d film which
for strange reasons was actually the
best part of watching the blu-ray
because yeah for my entire life I've
watched jaws 3 and I know it's not the
greatest movie but when I was a kid it
was kind of a thing for me like I liked
all the jobs yeah me too me too even for
when I was like oh yeah very young there
was parts of me that knew it was
terrible but I still wanted to see the
sharp parts yeah I mean I still went to
like Target with mom and no DVD at jaws
for as long I had to buy it because it's
John's exactly
so jaws 3 for me when I was a kid was a
big thing it was on TV I remember I
recorded it onto VHS tape my parents
were going to be working really late
that night I got home from school I
ordered some pizza and I watched jaws 3
and it was like a great thing for me all
these years later being able to actually
see some of the shots that were for
whatever reason on the screen for so
long when you were a kid like when they
pull the blanket away you see the dead
body they leave that shot for so long in
the movie in forever I was
was like why do they keep focusing on
this damn shot seeing it actually in 3d
was rather amazing yeah you really
marked out when uh like it revealed and
I actually really love 3d not just at
the theater but if I own the TV I
watched my 3d movies I like the
experience when it's done right when
it's done shittily like say a wrath of
the Titan this type of deal right no but
I really love 3d and really watching
this film I actually kind of liked it my
opinion I really like the underwater
stuff I really like the sunsets too but
for some reason looks so real underwater
one of the things I noticed in HD for
the first time is there is an absurd
amount of ADR in this movie audio
dubbing voices that were not there
people talk when their lips aren't
moving people's lips move and nothing
comes out like there's so much almost
like the entire film was post ADR for me
one of the biggest things I hate about
jaws 3 is that the shark moments are
terrible it looks so fake the shark
works still in Jaws and mostly in Jaws
to the shark in this movie is 35 feet
long it's basically a monster you know
this giant thing is like swimming
backwards and bumping things with its a
tail fin and like breaking through metal
cages with its tail the reason why I
jaws my opinion works so well because
that shark Bruce broke down so much and
we get more of the characters and
Spielberg really relied on those guys
and their interactions and the plot of
itself rather than show the shark men
sharks moments I think that's the
biggest reason why jaws every sequel
gets worse and worse and worse they kind
of don't care about that don't care
about the characters like my opinion the
characters in this movie ah they're sad
they suck so bad you don't root on
anybody now it's actually really sad
it's like a 180 compared to the first
film you're just like wow I love all
it's like a family or something you have
a crazy uncle and yeah it's your dad
it's great every single sequel just gets
worse and worse with that they just
don't care about the characters I don't
know if it's the writing or universal
well speaking of the writing I think you
had mentioned to me that the original
script was actually pretty good like
what are some of the big differences
between the original script and the
actual theatrical jaws 3 yeah real quick
before I dive into it I my head is
melting because I read this script like
three years ago ish and I just like
Reece Kim did before we wash her before
I came over to your place and my brain
after I watched the film it ended it was
just melted because how decent the
script was the scripts by like a seven
out of ten for me okay it was actually
pretty decent and I actually my notes
here there is so many like like
differences like for example we just
talked characters let's talk about
characters from the script compare the
movie in the script there's actually
some like decent funny one-liners like
there's so many attempts at humor for
this movie it just kind of feel like
maybe laugh once yeah I was like a brief
chuckle yeah and that was actually an
intentional joke be blasted tons of
other jokes that were unintentional
right those three teenagers that go in
the underwater Kingdom where it's called
they actually ever fleshed out a little
bit more like they have a lot of
dialogue like oh that guy look that
squid looks like a boyfriend I had no
sex with last night or whatever I was
like wow they removed a ton of stuff
then I don't know if they replaced it or
just completely cut it there's a couple
sequences in like the third actor later
in the second act where they were trying
to catch mama shark with a net and that
they remove that and then I think they
replaced the whole ordeal they're
supposed to have a little like chase
with Mike underwater and with Kate
underwater and the mama shark was like
chase Simon and then Mike's in a cave
and she's trying to tackle in the cave
and then it goes into the final control
room number so it last it felt right it
felt more natural and real in the script
was like oh my god over-the-top type of
deal when they goes into the control
room rather than it kind of felt like
cheesier forced in the movie it did in
the movie it was really obvious that it
was just trying to be a 3d effect like
here's the big part where the shark and
it's like this non moving image you can
see the white circle around it like in
the old original Star Wars cuts you
could see the white circles around the
TIE fighters and now you can see the
white circle around jaws as he very very
slowly approaches this glass and at the
end he goes Ironton open to the mouth
yeah they couldn't animate the tail move
out nothing just up it did look cooler
in 3d though oh hell yeah like the
opening titles looked amazing in 3d the
director of this movie
Joel Alves door every pronounce his name
I guess has been going around actually
trying to do little revival screenings
of this movie because it's the only film
he's ever directed really yeah Wow he's
been doing 3d screenings of this movie
and a lot of people are like you know
the movie isn't that great but in 3d it
actually it has like a meaning it has a
purpose of some kind I can say that I
never liked
jaws three and I still don't like jaws
three but I do like it just a tad bit
more when I can watch it in 3d and it
kind of becomes like this trashy guilty
pleasure 3d gimmick movie that's just
there to just be trash gimmick things
thrown at your face and laugh like the
shot in the beginning were the one dude
the beefy guy dies and his arm is like
coming right at the screen with these
two bones like sticking right out that
was pretty great actually it was pretty
good yeah there was stuff like that
where I can see if I was in the audience
in 1983 I would've been like well that's
cool and I might have like squeezed my
dates arm or something gotten excited or
whatever but like watching that movie
for the past 20 years of my life because
I saw a problem when I was like 7 for
the first time 7 8 years old I have
always been like what is with all the
shitty shot yeah her happy effects and
everything and now you can actually kind
of see what he was going for but the
film still sucks because like you said
the characters they just don't have
anything for them as characters the
romance is set up in like really one
shot where he's like I think I got a
call we're gonna go overseas and she's
like oh that's a long time and they try
to get her something you know yeah they
try to give him something and then the
idea of a shark being loose in SeaWorld
is so cool yeah there's so much stuff
you could do it
yeah that's why he liked it so much as a
kid yeah it was like well this would be
amazing yeah actually you pointed out
what was it called when they show
footage of something else in the movie I
forget but they did that like they
filmed it like Australia or something a
great white just swimming dock footage
stock footage you notice it first
there's just like swimming so fast yeah
whoo and I've seen this movie at least
like 10 times as I was a kid I never
noticed it and then when it's in like
the little tunnel or whatever it's like
was this guy it was almost like it was
drugged it was just there are shots
where it's artificially sped up like in
post and then there are shots like where
it's following the the people on the jet
ski and so it's like as fast as a
freakin cheetah yeah or something
it was born at least 50 miles now it
comes up the script has a lot of really
terrifying imagery and right there that
moment they have like a I don't know if
they have like a bird's-eye view of the
camera but they have the skiers and one
of them turns back it's like a dude he
goes oh shit and then it's like a above
camera angle you can see like the shadow
getting goosebumps just think about you
see a big-ass shadow right underneath
them that would be catechol so much cool
shit like that was cut like your time
characters just go how this movie was
set up from script versus the actual
film like Shawn shows up at an airport
and Mike and Kate go to the airport
he just ran he shows up at SeaWorld oh
there's Sean and everything you should
rather the cowboy pretty much yeah
so pretty much then on like the bar
scene with this fucking stupid
the standoff game what the hell is that
I never seen my my life music 70s racing
it must be like if you're drunk it'd be
hard to do like cuz I'm real life I'm
like how is it going like this with like
a very small woman supposed to be like
the problem all that shit and then them
like swimming in the lagoon the coral
divers I get eaten that's not in the
script at all that was all I gone it's a
completely different case yeah cuz that
whole shit could just be gone exactly
that's that's why I hear somewhere is
guys are gonna pay us some money from
all this coral oh this is a good stuff
here they store the head you just see
the wrapper I'm like okay that's a shark
moment they were I think they were
trying to make like in the first one
where the guys have this is my wife's
holiday Rocky yeah yeah roastin Anna
they're like I swear take my one card
don't look back yeah Charlie it might
have been like a pacing thing for like
people like I don't want to see a shark
attack where's the shark man yeah I
won't guess we'll put one in here on
some coral reef no but on all
seriousness the script Mike versus the
movie's Mike the Mike in this script was
actually like a pre what's the same as
the movie he wasn't too scared of the
water like Sean was but when he goes
into submarine Mike's kinda starts like
freaking eyes like I don't like this one
like the water look right when that
shark comes there's like insert cuts of
like from Jaws one when he's in shock
and the shark goes right by him yeah
this is not cool shit like that in the
script I'll go on fucking gone I don't
know what I don't Universal I don't know
why you choose to take a great film like
this one at 10 and at 10 and then Jaws -
they had actually some really cool
script elements I think you know of like
including the Mafia and like Amy's like
deserted and there's like no businesses
left Wow and then a shark comes in
attacks for Jaws - Kabuli gone they
decided to dumb down the script and then
dubbing down again the movie in the
audience think more stupid or something
I want to see great films like that I
want to see a petrified Mike in Jaws
three he has to overcome this fear of
sharks and that would be a lot better I
think it really is where the situation's
like he said where they they're trying
to dump something down because honestly
when I watched jaws 3 I don't see Dennis
Quaid and think that's the little kid
from Jaws I don't even think that in my
head even though it's supposed to be the
same character I don't even think it's
the same person because the film does
absolutely nothing to connect them and
the one part where he's talking about
his brother he moved to Colorado because
he's afraid of the ocean
and she's like what and he's like
yeah you know all those shark attacks
from before you know I talked about that
yeah once that one time I even bothered
with you know that time where I
witnessed a murder hey fellas hey boss
what are you doing over there that's not
how you die another way I'm oblivious to
the fin behind me hmm
such a great moment and for whatever
reason when I watched jaws 3 I never
think that's the kid because like you
said the script tried to connect the two
moments ya know some childhood fear
trauma yes never not just that but they
also have a picture of a chief Brody
he's like older he's got like this thing
kind of guy haircut like mine like a GI
cut and like yeah his dad you know dad
wants you to come to a me to get buried
and stuff like oh yeah do this sort o
pisses me off so Universal or whoever
made a choice you know with jaws 3 and
they decided to take it in a very
gimmicky 3d route because at the time it
was kind of becoming popular to do that
with horror movies for a while so I
think they were trying to cash in on it
yeah and also the jaws name appropriate
that you say that I feel like every film
from Jaws jaws 2 3 4 be going down it
feels like more like a Jason movie
earlier like a slasher shark film
Joelle's if you're watching this email
this guy I want that answer what the
fuck happened today that was good tell
us about jaws 3 the script had some
interesting moments the movie itself is
total shit the characters are awful but
for me especially watching it in 3d
today it has a very trashy
guilty-pleasure vibe to it where you can
sort of just watch it and laugh unlike
jaws the revenge which is painfully
boring and horrible in every way and
then don't you want to go over here
going you got to go outside Samoa
oh my god oh I'm gonna go on the banana
boat Nana I'm having psychic visions of
a shark it's coming near me I know it is
fucking yo-yo they need to do for Jaws
five Lauren Gerrie dies right and we
have the funeral then Mike's like you
got a fear haha Matt thank you very much
for being in this video I appreciate it
maybe if you want we can join together
and even talk about jaws too perhaps
because I movie called the shallows
coming out with Blake Lively a shark
film and my value commanders yeah that'd
be fine that that would be nice and
that's come on Blake oh haha I like a
sec I like you but in the trailer I
figured since the shallows is coming out
big shark movie I've already reviewed
jaws and jaws the revenge in hilarious
'ti form why not fill in the gaps and
review the other jaws films I haven't
reviewed so there is our review of jaws
three draws two will be coming up before
the shadows comes out hopefully if not a
little bit after I'm very busy with
reviews right now I'm also working on
reviews for the Bourne Identity
supremacy and ultimatum so that's all
going to be coming to you very soon
where can they find you Matt you can
look me up on the youtubes matt brando
you can see this stuff behind me i
reviewed that stuff and if you watch my
stuff i can buy the really expensive
shark from san diego comic-con 2015 it's
like a hundred dollars it comes with
bloody Quint and a bloody shark with a
machete it's freaking awesome yeah so uh
yeah watch my stuff check it out the
link is in the description it's give him
a sub he is worth it thank you so much
as always for watching guys we'll be
back very soon three four jaws - you
guys are the best and as always if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes